good morning hick it's Tuesday happy New
Year it's January 2nd 2024 which means
that 17 years ago today I uploaded my
first Brotherhood 2.0 video that's right
Hank the year was 2007 George W Bush was
president AFC Wimbledon were playing
their trade in the lowly seventh tier of
English football and most astonishingly
you couldn't check Instagram on your
iPhone because Instagram didn't exist
and neither did the iPhone Hank there
are so many YouTubers who are not just
younger than us they're younger than us
on YouTube that we're still making
videos is mostly a testament to our
community of viewers who've remained
astonishingly loyal over the years and
grown and changed with us I mean once
upon a time I was a guy who threw
himself against a wall to prove that he
wasn't an octopus and then later I was a
guy who gave a speech at the United
Nations and in both cases nerd Feria was
like oh yeah that tracks I'm just happy
to be on the road with these brothers
and because of that Hank this public
conversation between you and me has now
lasted for over a third of both of our
Lives we've each uploaded over 1,00
videos that have been viewed in total
more than 980 million times which is a
lot in some ways but it is less than 1
of The Views just for size video for
Gangam Style which points at something
important we've been very successful
we've been able to do this for an
astonishingly long period of time with
so many wonderful people but at the same
time we've never been like that
successful we've never gotten close to
the center of YouTube or culture or
whatever for me anyway this is where I'm
happiest I get to make stuff with
awesome people I like while never
amassing even over 17 years as many
views as Maroon 5 song girls like you in
short Hank I'm not old yet but I am old
on YouTube and there are downsides of
being old of course like I don't
understand all these new fangled
YouTuber techniques like custom
thumbnails but of course there are also
upsides to being old like I can
genuinely say about YouTube do not site
the Deep magic to me I was there when it
was written these eyes have seen a lot
of stuff Hank from reply guys to prank
houses and over the years I've had the
opportunity to see many different ways
of being a YouTuber and you know all in
all I like our way of being a YouTuber
like I never expected to be making
YouTube videos when I was 46 I don't
know if I'll be making them when I'm 50
or 56 but I like the job I like writing
and I like editing and I like that there
are so many lovely people on the other
side of the camera lens how how do they
fit all of you in there such a stupid
joke that's such a dad joke I said
before that I I'm not old yet but I am I
am old right so I like the job but I do
want to make a change over the last 17
years there have been many weeks maybe
four or five a year where I just don't
want to make a video sometimes it's a
mental health thing that's been quite
present for me lately other times I just
want to hang out with my family or I
have a writing deadline or whatever I
just don't want to make a video that
week and in the past I've always made a
video that week or at least almost
always like unless I was like
hospitalized or simply couldn't upload
because I was in a place without
internet I found a way to make a video
and usually I'm glad that I did like
there's a lot to recommend having a
schedule and sticking to it and I'm a
big believer in discipline when it comes
to creativity sitting down being
available to the work rather than
waiting to be inspired or whatever but I
think after 17 years I I know all that I
know how to have the discipline I know
how to show up for the work and there
still going to be some weeks where I
just don't want to or I have something
else that's really important if there
are weeks I don't want to make a video
I'm not going to which may hurt like
subscriber count or view growth or
whatever but at this point I'm not
overly concerned about that stuff as
long as nerd Feria stays strong and I
suspect that nerd Feria will stick
around because somehow they have even
amid an ocean of higher res algorithm
optimized content showing people living
in a bunker for a 100 days or whatever
over a 100,000 human Souls still show up
to watch these videos which is just
amazing to me so thank you for spending
part of your week with me and for
letting me do this for the last 17 years
it really has been the great privilege
of my professional life Hank I'll see
you on Friday